hi there steve coffman here today i want
to talk about japanese verbs and
japanese verb endings
but at first i want to make a confession
um
i do these videos based on stuff that
kind of crosses my mind for whatever
reason
and i do them without an awful lot of
planning because i
find that when it comes to languages and
language learning and talking about
languages
spontaneity randomness
is somehow more effective
than too much systemization
all right so i don't
plan like i have no terms to describe
uh japanese verbs the reason i'm on the
subject of japanese verbs is that in a
video that i made quite a while ago
about japanese i said there are no verb
endings to worry about in japanese and
someone commented and said there are and
of course when i think about it that
person is right
what i meant was that i have never
consulted japanese verb tables the way i
have consulted verb tables for spanish
portuguese even russian
and so forth because the verbs don't
change for person
and there are limited i shouldn't say
that they don't change for a person so
there's not as many different possible
endings
uh as for example in the case of of say
russian for nouns and adjectives there's
not that tremendous variety of endings
so how do japanese verbs work and why is
it that i never really looked upon them
as having verb the same verb ending
problems as these other languages
mostly i just got used to japanese
because in japanese
not only for verbs but for adjectives
and for nouns
stuff happens at the end that determines
the function of that word
so
if you say
like kaku
you know is to write
so
kakimasu
is a more formal so you've got kakimasu
if it's past tense it's kaki masta okay
but again it doesn't change for you i we
they
if it's
we might
right is kaku
so it's
uh if it's kaki mashtara
okay
so you have these endings uh
if you force get someone to write is
kakasareru
i find that i just got used to these
things by seeing them in context if i
look at a table of these there's no way
i can remember them all but if i see
them in different contexts and then i
question like why is this this and then
eventually you start to get used to them
but
you know if you have like yasui yasui is
inexpensive
like kakudaro probably will write yasui
inexpensive
even nouns
[Music]
so that basically i don't see them as
uh sort of verb endings per se i just
see them as
sort of
suffixes or
column endings
that have meanings
that are attached to verbs nouns
whatever
uh
and there's an unlimited number of them
and what's delightful in japanese is you
can say um
so that you can also the kaku can
sometimes become kaitara kakimashita
kakunaraba
is another way of saying it so that
there's this variety it seems to me in
japanese there's
two or three different ways of arriving
at the same result
we can look at a table of these in fact
it might be useful to get some kind of
an overall comprehensive sense of how
all this stuff works
but ultimately you just have to
expose yourself to enough of the
of the language in meaningful context
where you start to see these i'm trying
to think of some other uh
rabbis because
i don't know why but the naraba is there
again
i mean it's just all kinds of ways in
japanese and every language has sort of
that
almost
sensual delight that we get in using it
using the sort of idiosyncrasies of the
language in the case of japanese it's
playing with all these different
things that get stacked onto the end of
words to shape what we're trying to say
to put in
a certain amount of uh
again so typically japanese some
hesitation and a
chance to think about what you're going
to say and those are the delights of the
japanese language i don't see them as
the same kind of problem as case endings
in russian or in the slavic languages
where
you know ooh could be this case for this
gender and it could be something else
for some other gender singular plural
and it's it's this endless struggle to
try and remember these very specific
endings whereas in japanese you have
these sort of functional
uh suffixes endings
that can be attached to verbs adjectives
sometimes nouns and you just kind of get
used to them but if you want to consult
a list by all means do so so
again it's partly in response to this
person who said who corrected me when i
said there are no verb endings in
japanese in fact there are
but to me it's a different kind of
animal
and um
just the perspective and if this kind of
chat about specific aspects of different
languages is of interest please let me
know and please let me know what aspects
of which languages you would like to get
my perspective on so
thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
foreign